動画を見ているみんな！海に行ったかい？
中には受験生の方もいると思います
もうすぐ夏休み。受験生の皆さんはいよいよ 本格的な受験勉強
でもね！？でもねせっかくの海の日ぐらいはね受験生の皆さんも今日だけは
今日だけは受験のことを忘れてみんなで海に行きま…
勉強しろおおおおおお！
あっ…はい。
高校三年生の受験時代が一番人生で頑張ってました、はじめしゃちょーです
あのおー、受験生の皆さんもう休めないっすよ
夏になるともうみんな勉強しているのが当たり前なんで
今さぼるともうその時点で負けますから
こっからは勉強するのが当たりまえの戦いになるので
あとはいかに賢く勉強できるか、時間をとれるかで勝負が決まりますので
ぜひ、がんばってください。ごめん俺受験ガチ勢だったからさ
毎回なんですけど、あの頃苦しさを思い出せて
受験がある人には頑張ってほしいなといつも思ってしまいます、はじめしゃちょうです
とゆうわけで、新しいシャーペンが出ました！もう絶対皆さん知っていると思います
その知っているシャーペンの新型でございます
はい！こちら！きれいな文字が書けるこれで分かる人はわかるっしょ！クルトガです
クルトガの新型クルトガアドバンス！フエークシュン
なんかいろいろ細かく書いてあるね…夏風邪かな？
あとはちょっと細かく言っていくんですが
普通のクルトガと比べてクルトガエンジンの回転が二倍速になっているらしいです
学生時代ほど使ってはないですけども
シャーペンはたまに使っております。で！あの、やっぱりシャーペン業界とゆうと
一位はまだクルトガでしょ！シャーペンランキングを楽天市場で見ると、あーやっぱりクルトガ一位ですね
基本的にどのサイトを見ても
クルトガがやっぱり一位なんですけども
クルトガいままでに3種類ぐらいいろんなタイプを出してきました
ちょっと今持ち合わせてないんですけど、こちら普通のクルトガですね。シンプルな普通のクルトガ
ちょっと高め何でですけど、鋭くなったクルトガハイグレードモデル
あとクルトガにはアルファゲルのぷにぷにが合体した、uniアルファゲルのクルトガバージョン
この3種類が今まであったんですけども
満を持して！
やばい俺変態おじさんだ…
シャーペン変態おじさんだよ…
もう満を持して！進化したクルトガが出ました！
これが何を意味しているかわかるかみんな
そう！シャーペン業界はクルトガトップ！そのトップが新型のクルトガを出したということは！？
まさに！時代が変わる瞬間ですよ
はい！ハイとか言ったけどもうさっき出したんだけどね
はい！こちらクルトガアドバンスでございます。
えっとカラーリングが6色ございました。すごいね！もう色の展開が多いな
ちょっとと細かく見ていきましょう！まったくシャーペンの紹介しなさそうなチャンネルなのに、
急にこうゆうのがくるんすっよ…
あれだよ受験生の皆さん、あのー、シャーペンだけは
頑張っている君をずっと見ているから
まあ今回何が大きく変わったかと言いますと、とりあいずね、文字がきれいに書けるらしいんですよね
最近はやりの芯折れ防止機構ですね
先っぽが折れにくくなっているやつです
基本的にまあ性能としてはクルトガと同じなんですけども、
二倍速Wスピードがすごいっと
クルトガが何で回り続けるかというますと
クルトガエンジンがずっと回転し続けて
一回トン、一回トンとすると９度回転するのですけれども
今回wスピードエンジンになってからは18度回転するらしいです
つまりクルトガエンジンの回転率が事態が二倍速くなっているので
まだ書いてはないですけど多分もっととがるんじゃないかなっと気がしております
そしてなんか金属のパーツが新しく入ったっと
まぁ
見た目！！！！！
なんせもう見た目、ルックスがよくないと勉強のモチベーションも上がりませんから
クルトガと言ったら水色っていうイメージがありますね
おおーでも
かっこいいな！！先端が最初しまってる
プロテクションの部分が出てくるという、これで芯が折れにくいというわけですね
あう、あう、あでゅばんす、アデュバンス
シャーペンの上の消しゴムはなるべく使いたくないマンでした
はい！でました！あぁーなんか高級感があふれるね、エンジンが黒に金色のロゴになっております
あぁ、いいなぁ
やっぱ赤黒に限るね
はい！とゆうわけで僕の買ったのはこの2色でございます
持っているペンの色だけでもかなりモチベーションというかね
気持ちの変化はあるのかなと思っております
ホームページにあっただけなんだけどね…
ちょっとせっかく普通のクルトガ持っているんで見比べてみましょうか！
そんな見た目が特別大きく変わったわけではないんですけども
やはり！高級感が出ますね！金属パーツが増えたことによって
エンジンの露出部分が少し短くなっております
はい！とゆうわけで実際に書いてみましょう！
ヴぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁーー
まあいつもどうりなんですけどね
字がいいね！ごめんね字が汚くて…
やはりこの中に注目してほしいんですけども。
書けば書くほど中のクルトガエンジンが動いています
普通のクルトガの二倍の速度で動くのでかなりとがり続けるわけでございます
芯の先っちょがまるーくなっているんですよ
とがり続けているとはこういうことです
鋭さがかなりUPしているわけでございます
やあでもやっぱりあれですねクルトガの着地した瞬間
着地した瞬間のクルトガエンジンがどうしてもねじを回さなくてはいけないので
ちょっとくいっと基本的浮き沈みする感覚があるんですけども
それは相変わらず残っております
まあこれは…仕方ないことではあるので
まあ慣れるしかないと思います。慣れれば全然いけるんで
いや、でも、これは結構ありだぞこれはかなりいいぞ
もう全然昔のクルトガの１００倍以上は…
ひどい！！
ひどいよはじめん！！
なんでそんなこと言うの？ぼくが…
僕がずっと
一番だったのに！！！
あは、おおい、おちつけ！
はじめんは…
はじめんはもう俺なんてどうでもいいのか！？
いやまてよ！そーゆうわけじゃないんだよ！
うそだ！！！はじめん全然俺を使ってくれないじゃん！もうおれなんていら…ヴぇー
もう俺は用なしなのかー！？
ばっか、お前そういうわけじゃない
シャーペンたちが騒ぎ始める
うわぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ
どん！！
お前ら適当なこと言うんじゃねえ！！
シャーペン作るのに
どれだけ大変なのかわかってるのか！？
おれはな…
俺は一度もお前たちが必要ないなんて言ったことない！！！
いいかお前ら…
ひとにはな…
人それぞれの
あう、あわないがあるんだよ！！
誰が一番だっていいじゃないか…
誰がびりだっていいじゃないか！！！
世界には…
お前らが必要としている学生がいるかもしれないじゃないんだよ！！！！
分かればいいんだよ…
分かればいいんだけどお前が一番最高✨
ありがとうございました！！